earlier this year margot robbie  hilariously poked fun at her beauty  routine in an american psycho parody  video in the shower i use a deep Pore  Cleanser lotion I can't remember the  last time I washed my hair  it basically cleans itself now and now  the actress is dropping more beauty  secrets only this time it's not a joke  she really really loves beer showers  I've never experienced anything like it  so what exactly is a beer shower  well Margot explained to Harper's Bazaar  it's simply the practice of cracking  open in ice-cold beer while you're  enjoying a steaming hot shower your  usual choice but to special night  Margaux who admitted she's a bit of an  insomniac says it helps her unwind after  a long day she also revealed some other  hacks to get a good night's rest  I'm asks sleep music melatonin soothing  scents and when all of those fail she  can always count on her favorite boy  wizard Vargo gushed quote I read Harry  Potter before bed and it helps me switch  my brain off